hey guys welcome back to another session
by simply learn in today's session we're
going to be discussing the differences
between
java and javascript now when you hear
the terms java and javascript
it's likely that you get confused
between the two you might even use them
interchangeably
however there are a few differences that
set them apart
so in this session we're going to
discuss the differences between java and
javascript
so let's look at what's in store for us
first we look at a brief introduction to
java
then we'll look at a brief introduction
to javascript
then we'll compare the two languages
based on different parameters like
oop concept syntax variable definition
compilation platform compatibility and
finally salary
also at the end i'll help you understand
how simply learn can help you with it
so without delay let's begin
first up what exactly is java
developed by james gosling and team java
is the most commonly learned and used
programming language
across the globe more than 3 billion
mobile phones use
java today so mostly it is used for
android app development
it offers incredible stability and is
easily manageable
another important feature is that it
does not require any complex hardware
it is used in web applications with the
help of servlets
struts or jsps java overcomes drawbacks
of cnc plus plus
and provides better memory management
and security
now java products are storming the
market today
with over 1 million github repositories
it is no surprise that java has a vast
community
and a high demand for java developers
so now let's understand what exactly is
javascript
developed by brendan ike in 1995
javascript is a powerful server-side and
client-side programming language
users with the knowledge of javascript
can play around with any layer of the
application
one major feature of javascript is the
fact that it offers incredibly high
speed
javascript also provides wide range of
frameworks and libraries like
react.js angular and vue
javascript is used in integration with
html and css for web application
development
now another important feature of
javascript is the fact that simple
things can be done
simply javascript is also cross browser
compatible
and can be executed on any browser be it
chrome firefox safari and opera
it can also be used in conjunction with
other languages like
perl and php javascript has a wide user
community with over 600
000 repositories on github so now that
you know
what java and javascript are
let's go ahead and look at the major
differences between the two
first up is object oriented programming
java is an object-oriented programming
language
while javascript is a powerful
server-side and client-side scripting
language
now both these languages use the concept
of object oriented programming
concepts like polymorphism inheritance
encapsulation and
abstraction are readily deployed by the
two
so they make use of objects to perform
actions
however the only difference is that java
is a programming language
while javascript is a scripting language
moving on to the next parameter
syntax now java uses syntax that is
similar to c
or c plus plus while javascript uses a
syntax similar to c
programming language again since both
java and javascript use objects and
classes
syntax remains similar moving on to the
third parameter variable definition
now java is a strongly typed language
all the variables in the program need to
be declared before they're initialized
or defined
but in the case of javascript it is a
loosely typed language
variable declaration can be done as and
when they're used
next up is compilation java
is both compiled and interpreted now
every
java program is first compiled to byte
code
which the java runtime environment
understands now these
byte codes are interpreted by the java
virtual machine
making it an interpreted language on the
other hand
javascript is a strictly interpreted
language
in this case every instruction in the
program
is interpreted and checked for bugs
so java is both compiled and interpreted
while javascript
is strictly interpreted next factor for
comparison
is the running platform now java
programs and applications
run on java virtual machine now this is
generally installed when you install the
java software development kit
now this machine provides the platform
for executing the java code
it basically interprets the byte code
during execution
javascript programs are run on the web
browser
they do not require any initial setup so
all the programs written in javascript
are generally executed and shown on the
web browser beat chrome
firefox or any browser for that matter
moving on
the next feature is compatibility
now since java and javascript are such
widely used languages
there's no doubt that they offer
excellent compatibility
again java is cross-platform compatible
and is supported by operating systems
like windows linux and mac os
javascript on the other hand as
discussed earlier can be run on
different browsers
like chrome firefox and safari now it
also supports different operating
systems like windows linux and mac os
the last factor for comparison is salary
when it comes to java the average salary
of a java developer in
india is around 4 lakhs 47 000 rupees
per annum
while the average salary of a java
developer in the us
is around 74 000 us dollars per annum
in case of javascript the average salary
of a javascript developer
in india is around 3 lakhs 38 000 indian
rupees per annum
and the average salary of a javascript
developer in the us
is around 82 000 us dollars per annum
moving on to the last segment of this
session how can we help you
for that you can head to our official
website that is simplylearn.com
and type in the course you want to take
up for example
let's say java in this case it'll
provide you
three different results you have the
full stack java developer masters
program
there's also java certification training
you also have the automation testing
masters program
in case you wish to take up any of these
courses you can just click on them
and get a brief overview and depending
on your requirement you can opt for the
course
similarly you can also look for
javascript
and here you have certain results
there's a javascript certification
training course you have the full stack
web developer course
there's no js training and you also have
several articles
now if you wish to learn javascript
i highly suggest you go through these
articles they're very insightful and
help you with
tutorials and other concepts so with
that
we come to the end of this session i
hope the concept of java and javascript
is more clear to you
if you have any doubts let us know in
the chat section below
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here